Hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel. So after showing you my mental
breakdown of the worst trading session
of the month, I'm sharing with you in
this video the best trading session of
the month of October. Also, I want to
remember everyone that the platform that
I'm using it's a professional order flow
platform and it will be released on the
9th of November. So, click here to sign
up to the launch webinar.
So this is a commentary and a breakdown
of the session of October, the best
session of October.
So we came from a London session where
we did pretty good amount of profit.
That was around $10,000
and we start the session getting caught
by a little bit of choppiness here. So
we give back $5,000 to the market,
around 4,500.
And now I will comment the trade.
The first trades that we took was a
continuation short and we gave back two
trades inside here. We tried this
continuation and we failed. And now I
will show you the reason behind the
trades that we continue to take with a
maximum drawdown that is break even. So
if we go back to break even, we stop the
session.
So the narrative here it's really easy.
It's the one that I shared for free on
YouTube. So what I'm trying to see is
from when the buyers want to get
aggressive. So we see that this
consolidation area got completely
wrecked by buyers that took control. The
sellers got absorbed here. So what I'm
trying to do is capitalize on the failed
auction of the seller and then
aggression of the level of the buyers.
So I will be really fast in putting my
position to break even if this level
failed, okay? Because if this level
failed, this one become the new pivot
because the sellers, as you can see,
there are a huge amount of information
that the sellers are being absorbed
here. So I want to try uh good risk to
reward trades and amazing risk to reward
trades to take the top of the day.
And we will comment together how the
market behaves. This is the session that
uh we um did using the
uh big trades and uh the aggression of
the market. And as you can see, I'm
loading and scaling in position trying
to get my losses smaller and smaller. As
you can see, I'm only risking the profit
of the day, okay? I'm not risking more.
We are up a gain 9,000 for the day,
around 10,000 now for the day. And I
will continue to scale my position as we
go. I will speed up a little bit,
otherwise it will be boring for you
guys. As you can see, buyers failed
again. So I want to lower my risk
because if this big trade sell gets
stopped out, I don't want to be in the
position because we will have a really
fast snapback of the market. Let's go
on.
So as you can see, the market gives a
really solid aggression. My risk goes
really low and now I'm risking $980 to
make potential $25,000
of trades. Close the day above $25,000,
that is pretty good because in the worst
session that I can make, I lose around
5,000, 10,000. If we can manage to make
more than 25 session, it means that the
best session of the month it's two times
and a half bigger than the worst session
of the month. So this is a pretty good
maximum risk to reward balance for the
day. So now the buyers are in control.
Now it's a little bit tricky here
because you can cover behind this level,
you can cover behind this level. The
buyers took complete control. You can
see all these big trades. And you can
see that sellers are trying to protect
this level. So if we have another
breakout, we can trail our
stop in profit.
So what the market does, we have a
buyers wall, they try to push down. The
sellers got completely absorbed here and
the buyers are not making results in
this case. So it's a consolidation area
where if we break down this level, I
want to be risk free or with a really
tight stop loss because if we break down
this level, we will probably revisit
this level here. So it's pretty good to
manage your position with stop loss in
profit if you see something like this.
Let's go on.
As you can see, the market did a really
good acceleration of the sell and stop
before these aggressive buyers. Now my
position is stop loss to zero. Why?
Because we already saw that the sellers
got stopped again in the movement and
buyers are starting to continue up. As
you can see, big trades in the body of
the candle. Again, another effort but
still no result. Let's see who win this
battle.
As you can see, the buyers took control.
Now I'm covered below this low and I'm
getting a little bit of profit for the
market. So the worst case scenario, I
close $10,000. The best case scenario, I
close above above $25,000 for the day.
Let's go on. As you can see, buyers
stopped here. So no result from the
buyers but also no result from the
sellers. This is a potential
acceleration level here that we have.
Again, sellers took control but stopped
on these big trades. So I can
take other profit from the market. Now
the worst case scenario, we close
$15,000 for the day. This is a really
good process that you need to memorize
because this is a way to get back your
profit from the market as soon as
possible and not give back the profit
that you make to the market. Let's go
on. Let's see how it behaves. So the
market explode from this level. You see
all these aggression and a failed
auction and this is the reason I closed
my trade. But if I hold my trade here, I
remember that the day was pretty
directional here.
Okay? So I could have made 40, 50,000
dollar session but I prefer to be
conservative when I have a really good
sniper trades. As you can see, we loaded
the first one here, then we reloaded
here, then we reloaded here and this one
was our protection level. So we took all
the bottom of the up session of the day.
It was an amazing session and they
closed like this I just as you can see
here, there is still recording but
nothing is happening. The market just
skyrocket up. This could have been also
50 to 60,000 dollar day but uh I decided
to close. It was an amazing day and this
is the best session of the month of
October for one simple reason. We risk a
really small amount of money to make a
really banger day. So I hope you like
this content. I showed you before the
worst session of the month even if it
was recovered. Now I show you the best
session of the month and we can check
how it goes and I will update you on the
channel.